[Music]
lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or a licensed professional
[Music]
hello
it was
very cool
that you had a dream
last night
it was very cool that you had a dream
last night that
your friends were in a house
burning alive because they wanted to
and there was nothing you could do
except scream and cry
oh
that was me interesting because i was
about to correct you and say actually i
had a dream where i was apart on both
sides and different taking turns on
reenacting genocides so i would be both
the killing party and the killed party
and people would reenact them but we
realized each time i knew that there
were real bullets in the guns like it
was like a civil war reenactment but
these were like not real genocides in
the past like future genocides that
hadn't actually happened
and we had to like act them out
and then we would realize as as we were
acting them out they were really killing
us
oh god and then it would reset and then
i would be the killer and then it would
reset again and that would be the the
one we get and each time
oops each time i would be surprised at
tom cruise movie dude it's called the
killing party called genocide
future genocide so it's all good that we
have super [ __ ] up bro dude mine was
[ __ ] up man i was just like no
crying and somebody was just watching me
cry while one of my friends chose to
burn alive in a [ __ ] house but they
wanted to do it yeah i know but dude he
was still screaming and stuff anyway
dude it's sad
we hate to start um nicholas cage we
hate this hard we hate to start uh on a
somber uh down trodden uh
message but you got too many drinks man
so uh how about this i gotta how have
you been oh okay well that's cool how
have i been well i went worse therapist
dude you have too many drinks okay well
i like to drink them all water perrier
coca-cola
not something worth just checking out
dude
that's a coke uh i mean a blind taste
test
that's a period my head the way you like
it
all right all right okay all right all
right so speaking of blind taste test
you just straight up look blind
i went this weekend was a place i like
to call montreal which i love i love
montreal
because it's montreal
it's uh i love montreal first time ever
went there was with you why is that
camera not blinking in this blinking
okay good um first time you went with me
and you know what you said once when we
really said i will come to montreal with
you every single time you come and you
only went once you didn't ask me
but i went i went i didn't i went i went
because i uh had some uh movies in a
film festival up there and was invited
and paid for and yada yada yada bang
bada boom anyway i was supposed to come
back on monday but i had a bunch of work
[ __ ]
um
so i had to change my flight to sunday
the group i was with i had to go alone
okay i had to fly back along okay now
you know me okay you know
by the way i've been telling chris all
[ __ ] these last few days i got this
story for you i can't wait to tell you
but i'm not gonna tell you until we
start the [ __ ] podcast so you don't
know the story no and you keep talking
about how crazy it is okay it's the
craziest thing that's ever happened to
me all right
when i fell down an elevator shaft what
yeah what did that happen uh
butthead
in high school was in high school chris
uh
yes but you weren't the person who fell
down okay great wow so um so it wasn't
you so anyway so uh
this
story is the number one craziest thing
that's ever happened by far okay okay
so um since we just found out that the
elevator thing happened to chris this is
very viable and i keep waiting for the
[ __ ] cops to call me you know what i
mean okay so
um
i'm flying alone and you know me how
like nervous am i to fly zero right
exactly zero percent nervous i fly a lot
i never get nervous i'm just like
whatever we take off i [ __ ] fall
asleep before and i don't even notice we
took off
for whatever reason
i get i get there to flight [ __ ]
early because they're like get the early
get they're really good early because
customs takes so long custom takes me 12
minutes it never takes long dude and
there's like one every 20 times but the
fest people were like warning me warning
me right right
so i'm like okay i guess i gotta [ __ ]
anyway i get there in like i'm like
either three hours early wow and i'm
just waiting waiting [ __ ] waiting
waiting waiting waiting so dad and
finally we get on the plane then we're
waiting on the plane yeah and the time's
going going on i got a buddy picking me
up on the other end i'm like i don't
know i'm just getting like antsy and
i'm just realizing the limited space
around me i'm in an exit row but it's
not enough space
okay
and uh i'm just like i'm like my knees
tapping and i'm noticing myself getting
more and more anxious wow and i'm just
like ugh all right at least if we just
take off
it'll be uh you'll be on your way
exactly so
five minutes 10 minutes 20 minutes pass
finally we take off like 30 40 minutes
after we we're supposed to
we're in the air
and i'm good yeah
i fall asleep
i wake up
[Music]
and i'm like
oh [ __ ] yeah i bet we're almost we're
almost back in l.a i look at the flight
map thing okay and it's and it's three
hours and 11 minutes left okay so we're
not even close well you fell asleep for
[ __ ] four hours two hours okay two
and a half hours right so a little a
little less than halfway how far away
okay
so i
he's laughing i'm looking at 311
okay and
we've talked a little about a little bit
about anxiety attacks that we've had
yeah and the first one i ever had i
overheard this couple talking about
jerry o'connell and then i started
thinking about jerry o'connell and how
weird it is that he's so famous and then
my mind my mind just spun out and then
90 seconds later i'm like i can't see my
heart's beating
yeah joseph was a good man and
gonna give me one and uh i [ __ ]
that's so that's the context that's my
first anxiety attack i've had like two
or three total okay but they're always
in restaurants or weirdly lowly lit
places like one time i had one in the
stadium at night okay it's the way the
light affects me and sometimes the way
my mind spins out on spools okay in an
unforeseen way right okay so
311 but you don't pass out no i don't
know okay okay okay so it's 3 11 and i'm
thinking about uh three it's got three
hours and 11 minutes that sucks i'm
starting to realize this tight space
again everybody's asleep it's like a
night flight oh
and then i think about oh yeah there's
that band 311 and then i think about oh
i remember when that band 311 was
popular everybody said it was a white
supremacist band because three eleven
three k is kkk right right and then i'm
thinking about the kkk and then i'm just
like whoops you know my brain sure is
now falling out of my skull and i'm just
like [ __ ] ah and i got like a
millions of [ __ ] thoughts flying
through my head all uncontained and
unthought through okay and then i'm like
well at least a lot of time just passed
and i look at the flight map and there's
three hours and 11 minutes left okay so
like i'm losing my perception of [ __ ]
time yeah and i'm just like
but inside right right i'm not freaking
out on the outside i'm freaking out on
the inside because i'm a good person i
don't want to scare these people on the
plane yeah so i i'm actually like uh oh
this is gonna be an anxiety [ __ ] and
usually i have like you know whatever
[ __ ] xanax something around yeah
somebody with something even though i
don't usually have that sure
so i'm like somebody on the plane has to
have one maybe even if i ask the fighter
yeah yeah sorry so i go to the back and
i tell this flight attendant look okay
uh uh i'm i'm really sorry i'm not gonna
cause a scene i don't want to scare you
or anybody else but like i'm on the i
know myself i've had a couple of these
before in my life i'm on the precipice
of having an anxiety attack
and and uh uh i don't know what to do i
don't have any medication with me yeah
okay okay so she's really really nice
okay and she says okay well let me see
what i can do and it seems like she's
gonna [ __ ] figure something out right
yeah so she goes to the front to the
head of the flight crew
and and her and and one of the head of
the flight crew comes back two women now
okay okay they both come back and she's
talking to me about what she can do is
there anything and she's like well you
know maybe if you just talk to me and
i'm like
thanks right like i know what i [ __ ]
need right you know
so sh so she's like okay okay you're not
you're not telling her what you might
need i am i'm like it would really help
me if somebody had some kind of valium
or xanax or anything like that you know
they can't do that though right okay
so uh
so she's like okay okay and she's coming
up with suggestions super nice right
suck but she's being so nice yeah she's
clearly never had anxiety right she's
like what if we do a play right and i'm
just she's like you can pace around here
in the galley and i'm like i don't right
give a [ __ ]
but thanks right you know what i mean
right but i'm like being nice but like
short you know i'm just like thanks but
you know i actually know what this is
you know right right and uh and i know
you yeah and so i'm like okay she's like
well what we could do if you think it's
worth it we could call see if there's a
doctor on the plane see if he can talk
to you right here she can talk to you
okay and i'm like normally you know me i
would never do that right yeah yeah like
i'm like my heart's like about to pop
out of my chest right so i'm like you're
really going through it yeah dude and so
i'm like i'm like okay okay okay and and
they're like okay great
so nice okay wow so they call for a
[ __ ] doctor
this guy comes to the back of the plane
and he's like what's going on you know
and everybody's got a mask on except me
and they're like it's okay you don't
need a mask on i think it might have
contributed but i wasn't being like a
[ __ ]
shitty maggot guy like i don't wear this
[ __ ] i was just like i think this might
have contributed to my anxiety because
i'm feeling like contained
which sucks
and um
so the doctors all just as [ __ ] cool
just as great and they're like and he's
like so
it turns out he's a neurosurgeon at
cedars
okay so he's like my son has this exact
same thing happens all the time you guys
have a first aid kit right they're like
yes and he's like you guys have valium
and xanax and adivan in there right and
and she's like
yes and i'm like yes right why didn't
you say that dude well because she needs
a doctor clearance right exactly so
he's like get it out and he even now
he's like just give it to him yeah he's
got to sign all these papers he's being
so [ __ ] great right right my absolute
hero cool okay cool so he [ __ ]
he hooks me up and he's like he'll need
two but give him one and if it doesn't
if he's not feeling a lot better in 20
minutes give him the next one right okay
i take one feel a little bit better okay
good yeah good doing his job 20 minutes
later i'm like i'm still like my heart's
still racing it'll be better i've taken
this drug many times right i've been
prescribed it and uh by doctors kind of
yes exactly
and and he's like okay well she comes by
and she's like would the head of the
flight team would you like that other
one i can see you seem a little bit
still maybe nervous yeah and i was like
that would be amazing thank you so much
he brings me another one okay
now i'm like okay well the edge is gonna
go
now here's where the story turns oh my
god the woman in the row in front of me
turns around and says
hi
so nice
hi i heard you were having an anxiety
attack i get them all the time would you
like some of my medicine
she doesn't know at all that i've gotten
medicine from the flight people already
okay which is already a lot it's not
like i'm going to go [ __ ] passing out
or right right but it's a big dose two
milligrams of out-of-band is a lot
that's yeah okay
um so but me being me and not you yeah i
immediately say yes before she can even
stop asking
finish asking the question wow she gives
me a pill that i've never seen before
you already had the second one i know
right before this right before it
she so you should have waited for it to
say oh yeah okay oh yeah all right so i
should have waited i shouldn't even have
taken it right
so she hands me the pill
and in one motion her hand comes out my
hand goes out gets it and just
[ __ ] takes the pill right you ask
what it was
no dude i just it was just so stupid all
right okay okay so uh i take it mom and
dad sorry i know you're listening this
you're so [ __ ] freaking out right now
that's crazy i won't do it again i
promise uh
next thing i know
dude
i'm
coming to
standing above different people on the
plane
in the middle of conversations
and all of them are looking at me like
this and only i can see they're only
their eyes they're all like this
and they're they're scared we're really
confused i'm in the aisle standing over
them and every time i come to i realize
i'm scaring this person i don't know how
i got here i don't know what i'm saying
okay i don't know what i'm saying okay
okay hold on hold on
okay they're
where are they they're just they're in
their standards being good people
regular good calm collected good
citizens okay okay and i'm these are
passengers passengers okay and i'm
standing over them okay looking down at
them
probably really scary without a mask on
right
saying things that i don't even know
what they are because i don't know what
i'm doing because i mean there yeah yeah
okay so i wake up when i'm realizing i'm
upsetting someone only what
this happens
at least four times
one time dude
two of them i remember distinctly okay
one time
a guy is pushing me off of him
and i come too because he's physically
pushing me and i'm
like like i'm being pushed by a guy who
i don't know who it is and i don't know
what i'm talking to him about and but
then when i come to i'm just me again so
i'm like
dude i'm so
i'm so sorry i have no [ __ ] idea what
i'm doing i don't even know what i said
to you i don't know what i said you
whatever i [ __ ] said what i don't
know what it was and i'm sorry okay
the next one that i remember i'm
standing above this poor
middle-aged woman i'm sure a very nice
sweet person she looks [ __ ] terrified
and all i know is that i come to wake up
let's say saying
remember that you you don't remember
that okay you don't remember that
and she's just like
like so scared you know what i mean and
i feel so bad because i'm the one
scariest person and i don't even know
how i did it right right okay so then
finally i'm back in my [ __ ] seat and
the guy next to me actually i mean
everyone on this plane was so nice the
guy next to me was so nice
i guess i gave him uh my my email
address at some point right oh my god
okay
so he emails me just to see how i'm
doing like the next day oh okay okay so
and you get off the plane everything's
okay yeah dude i find a guy picking me
up the next day he was like you were
[ __ ] up what the [ __ ] you know what
happened last night i was like i told
you he's like i know but dude what the
[ __ ] well i dropped you off at a
7-eleven well i i picked you up and took
you to 7-eleven you came out everyone in
the 7-eleven was like dying laughing
at you i was like i don't remember that
even a little bit right so uh
the guy who i was sitting next to him
and his wife they were coming back from
italy he's like
he emails me just to see how i am okay
right and i'm like oh dude i'm [ __ ]
great like i feel great thanks for
checking in how you doing like i
remember you're a really nice guy yeah
but i know what's up yeah yeah i mean i
know why he's just at your worst yeah
and so i [ __ ] i'm like hey do you you
know what i was doing right
and he was like yeah like yeah kind of
everybody knew right oh my god and like
uh
i was like did i like do anything really
bad yeah yeah yeah and he was like
actually no it was just like you were
being like really weird and i was like
what was i doing and he's like well i
don't know because i didn't hear all of
it like no one did but you at the one
point the woman that i was like do you
remember that do you remember that do
you remember that yeah
uh
she was like you were asking if she
remembered
the the band pearl jam
and if she remembered the song daughter
and when she wasn't responding you
started singing it to her
yeah oh yeah
oh my god dude thank god i wasn't there
hmm they got no one i know was there no
meander not from town
dude on a plane
to a stranger with no mask on looking up
at me [ __ ] terrified so what no
picture can't well remind
me just like scaring everybody dude what
did the flight attendants do nothing
dude they let me run free because i
wasn't like
really doing anything i guess i mean
that's kind of harassment it is
harassment dude and i [ __ ] feel bad
i feel bad
i mean i feel terrible dude okay okay so
hold on so all right so
holy [ __ ] dude and you don't but that's
crazy that that you can be standing up
doing stuff you don't even you're not
even aware and i'll tell you the
craziest part is that when i would snap
into it yeah
i was just me again and i remember all
of that right so so the fourth time it
happened were you like [ __ ] another one
of these things again because you knew
it was happening dude it was like what
the [ __ ] like sit in my chair
[ __ ] oh wow dude like i'm two
people
dr jekyll and mr two people dude dr
jekyll and mr matt and the moral of
stories i'm two people
oh man
yeah that is crazy dude do you remember
probably i'm like the chris farley show
you know like i'm interviewing eddie
better on the chris farley show
the lady and then you walk out hey do
you remember pearl jam
uh do you remember daughter i i don't
know don't call me daughter what the oh
sorry ma'am
well that was probably the scariest part
to them where i just turn into somebody
else yeah yeah yeah
whoa dude i wonder what that pill was
dude it was bigger than an adivan in
blue
this is the matrix you were in the
matrix dude maybe the blue pill maybe i
was the guy that didn't give you the red
pill then you really would have been
yeah i did then i would know i wouldn't
even [ __ ] be here yeah oh my god well
that what's your advice is don't take
medication that
isn't
that yeah did that that was it oh wow so
she gave you xanax don't take xanax and
advent together yes don't take a lot of
out of van and a lot of xanax together
who knew
what what is the dosage on that side
what's the size of the pill like what's
the milligrams on that one
anyway it was a lot well the advice if
someone called in for that would be
don't mix medications if the doctor
doesn't tell you to yeah she didn't
prescribe that uh why did you take it
wait what's the 605 what's it what's
that one
that's uh
oh alprazolam as i said yeah al
weird i'm proud of xanax yeah weird
alprazolam prize
[Laughter]
[Music]
that was me dude weirdo prize lamb
that's the pill that's it
i think you gave a [ __ ] big-ass nx
after the two big ad event oh you took
an alprazolam i mean i i i've taken
alprazolam but but i wonder what the
dosage was she probably gave you a
[ __ ] zany bar dude yeah i was
i took the whole thing i didn't break
anything just yeah
it was probably two two uh
two mil to whatever yeah two milligrams
yeah because i do like a point two five
and i go to sandy island if i go to if i
take a point if i take a half of a
milligram of xanax i'm like
yeah [ __ ] children if you pick up
point five you go to zany island for a
post up for a few [ __ ] days you know
yeah and if you take a whole new [ __ ]
take two you just you go to zany planet
you're across the country yeah right
across country xanax
all right cool all right well let's do
it let's do that sorry i just had
yourself that's an amazing story
it's the craziest thing that's ever
happened to me really because i don't
remember things i was doing that were
definitely scaring people
and i don't like that yeah you know
jesus christ thank god you're not famous
all right oh my god it was a dark flight
and everybody was asleep i'd be on
[ __ ] reddit by now for sure oh yeah
right yeah and people would be like
that's matt daley yeah yeah yeah we'd
get bigger ratings which would have been
good actually that's well that is yeah
that's the craziest thing that's ever
happening definitely all right uh well
before we get into it we were gonna do
this but uh i got um
dates coming up i will be in grand
prairie texas dallas
uh august 26th wichita kansas august
27th atlanta georgia september 9th on
washington d.c september 10th stockton
and oakland i have a bunch of dates go
to chrislea.com cheyenne wyoming denver
colorado boston massachusetts albany i
have a bunch of dates go check it out uh
chrisleya.com get get your tickets it's
uh you know they're selling so uh thanks
uh all right let's do it yeah
let's see who it is it's that's the the
the
dead guy he's survived please jake man
that machine says probably uh the first
thing you're going to say and this first
thing most girls say is like
like good hygiene
no uh
i mean okay i think died to add to one
of the problems of i mean this guy is
wait hold on stop it he's always dying
he stopped in the middle he started in
the middle of of the video mm-hmm play
it again from the beginning again it was
so low if that was the lower his eyes
recovered just a pair please jake man
the guy from that machine says probably
uh the first thing you're going to say
and this first thing most girls say like
you like good hygiene
i mean no
died
that thing died this guy dies
you know what happens he goes back into
he goes back in time
and and he experiences a whole year and
then comes back like or you know what i
mean like goes to the future experiences
a whole year yeah and then fixes the
world and then comes back that's what
happens yes
like we would all died with an asteroid
would have hit us and killed us but he
saved our lives right there
go back go back and see how he saved our
lives
what right here watch when he saved
planet earth like good hygiene
saved the planet saved humanity right
there one of the problems of
why
i had to ask for advice is because i'm
sure you couldn't see that
answer for that
um
should we just go for taller women or
i mean
you look shorter than your wife or is it
matt are you are you taller than yours
what i don't know if that's the issue i
look shorter than my wife yeah you look
shorter than kristin hopefully she's not
my hygiene i know that for a fact but i
don't know what should i go to bars i
wouldn't i don't like bars i don't
really like drinking
so if you made it let me know saved
humanity three times we would have been
extinct all right all right
so it turns out that he's short okay
okay that's it first of all how short
second of all i don't look shorter than
kristen i don't know dude this guy's got
a couple things going on
but
dude you're [ __ ] handsome and you're
so confident you fall asleep in the
middle of questions you're cool you're
like matt you fall asleep and wake up
and then you're standing above
somebody's singing pearl jam dude um
you and him are basically marvel
avengers you know right right the worst
the two worst ones well he's saving the
world and you're just kind of singing
singing karaoke to people on planes um
yeah
don't do i go to bars is what he's
saying dude i always think that meeting
if you're gonna try to meet a
significant other going to bars is the
worst thing yeah like you do you the
people who are at bars
are not looking to i mean pretty much
they might be but no no but but not but
you're at a bar dude you go there to get
drunk you know what i mean i mean i yeah
i agree yeah so it's like you're looking
for the people who are trying to do
something
to
something reckless
do you know what i'm saying i mean i
think i think people are speaking trying
to [ __ ] if he's just trying to [ __ ] i
guess go to a bar but i think he's
trying to find a girlfriend right that's
what guys go to bars for women don't go
to bars to [ __ ]
they don't maybe not generally speaking
as much but you know they go to hang out
with the girls
have a night out and then they come home
and do a ouija board or some [ __ ] i'm
just trying to say he seems like he's
looking for a relationship and don't go
to a [ __ ] bar for that just like be a
guy in the world who is as confident as
you are you're [ __ ] so confident
you're falling asleep in the middle of
questions just even though you're short
and obviously it doesn't matter you're
sure you [ __ ] have confidence that's
all that matters dude and i don't mean
like boastful [ __ ] assholery just
like being a person on earth who's
comfortable with who you are that's all
and you clearly are you're falling
asleep in the middle of between words
i'm saying i'm saying it so much yeah he
he but also be maybe be more engaged sit
up sit there talking to people you know
talk a little faster don't maybe don't
fall asleep in the middle of the
sentence yeah i mean this guy like this
is this guy
yeah man i'm just thinking you know nice
meeting you at this bar you know maybe
we just hang out
[Laughter]
maybe we hang out sorry i was tr so what
had happened was
in 40 years
she's just walking away already
in 40 years humanity is at a standstill
i had to go fix uh
basically the all the sperm cap
scientifically i had to go fix the sperm
count in men because it was dying and it
was at the crux of the situation where
we was all gonna be extinct anyway what
are you getting
my friends what's that
i'm going to go join my friends
[Laughter]
thank you
i mean yeah the [ __ ] guy's just he's
sitting right it's right in front of him
dude you're a confident guy be be that
and talk to women and don't be a creep
that's so simple just those those things
all right you're good all right and yeah
if he's asking about hygiene and be
clean too yeah be clean but no but a
little bit of beard is good though yeah
girls say that because i don't know what
else this isn't like bad hygiene i know
people are always like oh crucial you
look like you don't shower bro i shower
oh yeah how about this i shower more
than you dude yeah maybe i do i shower
at least once a day at least at least i
never go a day without showering never
ever ever i do what i went one day
without showering in the past however
many years and it was when i got my nose
surgery jesus hey dude
oh you all right you're [ __ ] having a
stroke
[Laughter]
all right dude next one
what's up fellas got a question i can
just help i'm 28 the last six years
since i graduated college i've been
saving up for a down payment on a house
do so and what should be an extremely
exciting time for me is kind of being
clouded by a girlfriend who i've been
living with the last two years
pretty much said that she's not going to
move into a house or
even be with me if i buy a house without
her on the mortgage personally i don't
believe i should be on a mortgage with
someone i'm not married to i'm just not
ready for that at this time and she's
also looking at my bank account saying
if i buy a house i won't have enough
money for a ring which the brinks
headquarters is in my backyard right
just so you know okay question do i
proceed with buying the house and if so
how do i break it to her that it doesn't
matter i'm going through with this [ __ ]
that's so sexy the way you just said
that that guy's a sexy guy that's what
she wants you to say buy the house bro
this is crazy doesn't sound like a fair
deal i don't know why am i missing
something yeah yeah no she's being not
if what he's saying is true right i'll
assume that right don't buy a house you
won't have enough to get a ring
oh he said a ring that's what he said oh
dude wow and then he said and then he
said i don't want to you shouldn't buy a
house unless i'm on a mortgage dude
those are two
how those flags are burgundy dude like
you gotta you gotta make sure to just
this is like these are two red flags
this is not good dude she said she
doesn't want to move in the house with
unless she's on if she's not on the
mortgage say great thank you and just
buy the house and move in yeah i'm going
to get a house i'm going to move in
you're welcome to come with me
yeah you're welcome to come with me
right but this is not happening we get
married i could put you on the [ __ ]
[ __ ] i could put you on the deed or
whatever it is right but like like let's
let's work towards this together i'm
with you we're not on different teams
we're on the same team we want the same
goal but right now you're [ __ ] you're
jumping when we should be hopping right
yeah this is a red flag dude these flags
be burgundy as [ __ ] man wow it's that
time of the month for these flags dude
why's uh
these flags are [ __ ] need a tampon
right right up soaking next to him dude
wow are you kidding me man just didn't
let the metaphor sit there i had to
explain it in bloody detail like i'm
saying the flag would be inside of
these flags are inside between le you
know of the women and it's that time of
the month okay okay so i don't
think that's a very good sounding
relationship though too to robot to
further to further my advice i don't
think that's a very good sounding
relationship
i don't think that's a very good
sounding
relationship am i right
it sounds bad yeah and i could tell by
the kind of guy you are and the face you
have the kind of relationships that you
get into and i know what's going on bro
okay why don't you tell him no because
honestly that's for me and him to be on
that wavelength and understand it you
know what's going on bro you know what
to do okay you're being a little bit of
a [ __ ] guy that's like what do i do
but you know what to do and that's why
she liked you in the first place and
that's what works for the relationship
or get to step in
and that's that dude
okay
all right there we have it next one
okay so much headroom hey guys
chris i watched you play
now i know we just said guys with beards
don't necessarily have bad hygiene
this is not an example of that we don't
know that though maybe he showers every
day
let's just look at the surroundings we
look and judge everything we're judging
we are judging you that's what we do
best guys i don't judge you right we'll
go here we go
too much also matt you're hilarious and
thank you huge fan hey i mean i'm here
but guys guess what what's up my baby
gets to come home soon three months in
the hospital oh no my wife is still up
there hour and a half away driving back
and forth oh yeah and he finally gets to
come home oh so pumped
that's awesome yes dude wow
um but i want to surprise my mom and dad
he's named after my dad okay clinton so
we call him little clint cute what's the
best way to surprise my mom and dad
because i they don't know he's coming
home soon they know he's coming home
someday right but what's the best way to
surprise him
guys i love y'all
i'm super anxious i have filmed this 40
times
look thank you
we love you dude guy couldn't be sweeter
man congratulations take back that
hygiene [ __ ] yeah
i [ __ ] up did we judge and we live and
we learn right we live in maybe he's not
part of duck dynasty but if that guy
hasn't shot a duck i would be [ __ ]
absolutely shy he's probably i don't
judge but he's shot a duck he shot a
duck and so um look um i i i think that
this is one of those things that
you is so beautiful and so amazing that
you don't necessarily want to do
a thing
and have it overshadow how beautiful the
moment is i think the surprise is just
the fact that it's happening surprising
them is fine but have them show up and
be like guys i have a surprise for you
the baby's here
like i don't think that there needs to
be some sort of what's the best way to
surprise them because the surprise is a
surprise within itself and it's already
the most beautiful thing in the world i
agree about the baby the name could be a
cool surprise you could when when you
know the name right oh the other day
when you surprised it with the kid
that's that's good but then take the
baby's shirt off and have it say clinton
and a tattoo on it no that's too you
shouldn't tattoo anyone uh tattoo the
baby was just born with clinton on it no
cross the chest
oh man that's emotional actually not
that tattoo thing but like just have
just be like clinton meet clinton jr
that would be really sweet that would be
really really sweet
clinton's a cool name actually clinton
meet clinton first name
uh but yeah i don't know i mean i agree
with you actually you don't want to like
get caught up plus you want to enjoy it
you don't want to get caught up in like
the surprise has to be great like the
surprise is the the thing is already
agreeing already it's already the best
exactly exactly um
yeah don't overshadow something small
and cute if you really want to do
something but don't make it a whole
thing yeah yeah
okay cool
hey chris hey matt i'm a huge fan of the
show um just a huge fan in general i
will be in jacksonville in december so i
look forward to seeing chris then uh but
my question today is about my boyfriend
and golf so
genuinely greatest boyfriend in the
world i know everyone says that but he
is incredible i don't really have any
complaints other than he's recently been
playing golf like more and more over the
past year or so to the point where it's
like three four times a week and
sometimes he'll go at like four pm it
doesn't get home until like nine pm
which kind of interferes with our chill
time
we'll like leave town on the weekend go
golf in other places i just feel like
he's starting to put it before me in
certain ways i'm happy he's passionate
about it but i just kind of wanted to
get your opinion if you feel like i
should say something before it gets to
the point where it starts to interfere
with our relationship just want your
general take on guys who are super
obsessed with golf um so yeah just want
your opinion and thanks for letting me
come on the show
his cheat
[Laughter]
is that what we call it golf
i mean all guys thought just the same
any guy listening to that was like oh
[ __ ] dude so does he leaves town for the
weekend uh and goes to cabo and [ __ ]
the golf courses smell like perfume and
coming back smelling like a lot of
perfume yeah perfume
uh
i thought they golf he said it was all
day golf all you should do is say he's
not cheap we're joking yeah all you
should do is say
hey babe
i love to see you golf every time you go
send me a picture of you on the golf
course
because you think that
then you can appreciate cheating oh i
don't think he's cheating yeah i mean if
he's cheating he's a [ __ ] idiot from
saying he's always golfing right yeah
it's so easy to [ __ ] fight he just
gets dressed up and [ __ ] clackety
clack clack crack out the house and then
just i think
man that wrong
with the [ __ ] you know what i mean
oh oh about to finish four
i mean i
if the question is should you say
something
definitely that's too that is so much
[ __ ] golfing that is an obscene
amount of golfing that's the guys the
guy can't stop golfing cannot stop going
on a golf
three or four times a week goes away on
the weekends to go golfing yeah four p.m
to nine p.m that
is too much to do time thing is weird oh
it does stay light it does stay light to
later especially if you're in the south
but it's too much to do anything though
it's too much time doing anything
besides
work
yeah what does he do is he hey is he a
golfer what the [ __ ] what did she's like
by the way my boyfriend is [ __ ] tiger
woods phil mickelson by the way my
boyfriend is that [ __ ] guy with the
weird haircut who was super fat and
[ __ ] huge mad guy oh john daly
nicholas nicole nichol john daley oh no
john daly yes um yeah uh i mean dude
just be like why do you [ __ ] golf so
much how about that man take it back to
the [ __ ] old school dude you want you
want to go back to the 90s with this
dude and be like hey by the way why the
[ __ ] do you golf so much yeah what are
you running from dude
what are you running from that maybe is
a little too confrontational get to work
base it but when you do bring it up
don't be like don't do what he's saying
at all don't be like why do you like to
golf be like i'm kind of missing you and
i think
maybe we could cut back a little bit so
we kind of split it a bit more because i
think you're home less and less and i i
would like to have time
with us quality time in our relationship
that isn't necessarily like rushed
because you gotta [ __ ] go out to play
golf waking up at [ __ ] 1 a.m yeah you
got to go golf yeah going to golf babe
it's night time
can't stop golfing dude uh
it's so funny to think like what if he
is cheating and he's just is so
disrespectful that he won't think of
even another lie like he's just like
golf yeah where were you golf
showing up in like not golf clothes i
was golfing
uh so wants to get caught yeah yeah um
that's just too much golf that's too
much anything honestly if he was hanging
out with you that much that'd be
annoying that's what i'm saying it's
it's too much of anything he's
maybe he's an addict he's got that kind
of personality but like yeah yeah yeah
yeah and maybe it'll burn out soon but
bring it at least bring it up but but
honestly when you do don't make it sound
like a judgment about on him about how
he likes to golf
make it about you
and how you're me either missing him or
thinking maybe you should spend more
time together i don't know i think you
should be judgmental you should be like
god what cookies golf huh a lot lately
and he says yeah well and she'd be like
i just i don't know i wouldn't do that
if it were me well she's not gonna get
what she wants if she does that be
passive aggressive all right next
holding her head on hey guys love your
show love your energy
laugh um
here's my question for you
so i have a
person in my life who anytime i share a
story with them about
something that happened to me that week
or
it doesn't matter in the past
their response to my story is to share
with me yeah a very detailed one-up
story oh dude better than my story
and
i didn't notice it at first but once i
started to notice that she was doing
this all the time um i would just kind
of
like busy myself her boyfriend just left
around me to try to
give her some social clues like hey shut
up i don't care it's not that i don't
ever want to hear a story from her it's
just she does this every single time
well i started noticing that she does
this to other people
and their responses are very similar to
mine where you can just tell that they
immediately become worse it's terrible
kind of thinking the same thing like hey
shut up
so my question to you is i'm not sure
whether this habit of theirs is born out
of like
some narcissism or
the spectrum just insecurity
should i say something to them and just
like hey do you realize that you do this
and stop doing it
thanks guys
okay the first thing is
she thinks that's how you have
conversations she's not trying to one-up
you no i don't think yeah i think that's
how you're supposed to talk well she's
just wrong but even though even though
even if you're not right which you you
definitely could be i think that you
shouldn't uh
that you should err on the side of she's
not doing it to try and [ __ ] one-up
you she's definitely not yeah okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah not cool definitely
not that but i honestly think that when
people do something that peop that makes
people uncomfortable like that they're
they're it's it it is probably rooted in
some kind of insecurity but it actually
is how
they think a conversation is supposed to
go they think they're doing it right
yeah maybe that they're insecure and
sort of panicking coming up with
something right just to say it but i
think it's still worth bringing up and
you can ask
i don't think you should say stop doing
that but you can ask why she does it you
could do that or you could [ __ ] do
the exact opposite which is make a
crazier make your stories crazier and
crazier so she can't [ __ ] match your
stories tell her [ __ ] yeah well dude it
was crazy i robbed two banks one summer
what do you gotta say to that dude and
she want people to match you and then
she'll realize the error of her ways hey
i jumped out of a plane
twice once with a parachute on and the
other one i found a guy falling through
the sky with a parachute on and i
grabbed him and we both parachuted down
what do you got to say to that she'll
realize the error in her ways and then
she'll probably stop doing it
yeah or you could just ask her why she
does it yeah either one is equal
um i just you know people like this are
so annoying i like
it's like you know a lot of comics do it
but it's like let the joke i live in
this world where i'll do it and then
people like i like to let people's jokes
kind of breathe you know they get the
laugh like somebody says some [ __ ] and
before i tag it up and give it a [ __ ]
one two you know let me put that joke on
the [ __ ] speed bag do you know what
i'm talking about before i start [ __ ]
dang it dang it
with the joke that's out there [ __ ]
drying in the air before i do that i'll
let it hang okay
and then i'll [ __ ] put it on the
speed bag and dang it to dang it up
right and i respect if somebody lets me
do that with my joke too if i do a joke
and then they [ __ ] come in like joe
coy and just oh yeah and also this and
[ __ ] don't let my joke be carefree
and fancy out there for a little bit
it's annoying as [ __ ] dude stop doing
that joe coy do you understand what i'm
saying
okay sounds like you got a little bit of
a deeper issue it's just he would always
do it when we hang out and [ __ ] and it's
annoying okay
so yeah that's annoying and you are
right to be annoyed by that but i think
uh know that she's not trying to compete
or would not be
thinks that's how conversations actually
go give her the benefit of the doubt but
feel free to ask her why she does it
however try not to be like
stop doing that i hate when you do that
anything like that uh you're more likely
to get the result you want if you just
ask her and sort of probe and she'll
probably get the idea right okay
cool next okay can't believe you hey
chris matt love the show i need some
quick advice so i got a message from my
ex's brother's wife um they want to do
an open relationship um she said she's
interested in me but it's weird
because i know her family i know that
they have kids it's a new thing for them
and i don't really want to be the guinea
pig but dude she's so
[ __ ] hot okay
um
i thought about her before he let that
dude come out right there you see a hot
woman you think about it and
dick says yes brain says no um
who's nick so what do i do
thanks guys hi i'm dick yes um so i'm
sorry i need
time to process that x's brother's wife
yeah
x's brother wants to bring this guy into
the bedroom so basically his former
brother-in-law almost not even though
they weren't married not really his wife
ex's brother but not ex-wife right right
right
okay um
okay and they want to have an open
relationship and and the brothers
assuming uh he's okay with the two they
agreed to have an open registration yeah
and they want to use this guy i mean
[ __ ] her what do you what
do it yeah
well i don't understand i mean well i
mean it depends on how close he is with
his ex if it's if it's a [ __ ] ex of
three weeks it's horrible idea oh yeah
if it's an excellent five years i
assumed it was a long time if you're not
in the person's life then
yeah i assume that was a long time yeah
you're right i mean it's definitely
gonna make her feel a certain type of
way if you don't give a [ __ ] and if it's
been six years then okay i don't think
it matters that much but if you guys
just broke up and you like literally
like if she was like if you were like
it's over hey what's up chris and matt
like if you did it like that right yeah
then you're gonna [ __ ]
doing this is definitely going to make
your life more stressful than it is i'll
i'll say that so in that respect
it better be very boner inducing do you
know what i mean but let's assume like
most people he doesn't even talk to his
ex anymore that yeah that's over with
and it's done with and it's in the past
yeah if this is some like think of it as
somebody again yeah maybe you're going
to hear from here it's going to make
your life more stressful and i'm just
saying that stress has to equal the
inducement of the boner do you
understand yeah i do but she
asked him right yeah she asked him yeah
it wasn't his idea okay yeah i mean even
though he looks at you from lincoln park
it wasn't his it does yeah and so what
you do is you balance you take the
stress to the boner inducing scale you
take it to the bone reducing skill
that's what you do you say kenzie
dude remember when kinsey had the orgasm
in the movie when liam neeson was
playing him and he was like i can orgasm
in like 12 and in like two seconds you
know and he just goes
dude kenzie was a [ __ ] up guy i know
dude i just watched a documentary and it
[ __ ] mentioned him and apparently he
would do crazy [ __ ] up [ __ ] and have
crazy scales made like 11 month olds
come
hey kinsey
you're cancelled no no i know but
like what the [ __ ] we're catching john
wayne because he says something in
playboy magazine
you made 11 year olds come i know 11
month olds come i know dude crazy [ __ ]
dude canceling people because they
[ __ ] you know what i mean god because
they were on remember when they tried to
cancel roseanne barr for doing the [ __ ]
that you did because you tweeted
something on ambien
do you know what i mean and yeah i
almost got roseanne yeah yeah you almost
got [ __ ] roseanne but the [ __ ]
like she said something actually racist
which is actually pretty [ __ ] up it is
i know but she didn't know she didn't
know but i know but it's harder to be
like i was on ambien when you're like i
don't remember what she's being remember
what she did me neither i think it was a
racist thing okay i don't know
uh anyway uh but yeah quincy's can
kinsey's cancelled
you should just [ __ ] that woman yeah uh
you have to put on the scale on the
boner inducement scale kinsey
you have to [ __ ]
look at it and be like the straw the
stress level is so so where you look and
you get a six the stress level is at six
now when we bring it over to the boner
inductor
boner and doctor you know we we look so
not scientific we look at the boner
inducement of this you know we look at
her hourglass figure and we look at her
titties and there it'd come out further
than her hips but her hips at the bottom
become big so that is titties
we
we
equate her boner inducement to a 7.5 so
you have 1.5 to play with the stress is
six and the boner induction so what it
is you have a point you have a point 1.5
plus on the bone reducement scale so go
have an open relationship deleted scenes
from mckinsey
and cut we got it
all right yeah all right yeah
[ __ ] lifeline it's uh it's mr cuban link
from foreign indiana oh wow jesus i hope
you guys are in your three-seater
ferrari with your dad yeah top down
titties exposed okay that's right it's
got a little lifeline
uh
we planted some pumpkins out in our
backyard okay
uh july on the left side of the trees is
my property on the right side as my
neighbors
planted our pumpkins on the left side of
the trees
then a couple weeks later uh neighbors
mowed it over oh
pretty pissed about a uh
little brm
well what do you guys think the
repercussions are for that
let me know i know i know what the
reproduction pumpkins on their side
yeah yeah
threat syndrome plan yeah for real
pumpkins on their side
direct confrontation
eye contact direct confrontation knock
on the door knock knock knock door opens
direct eye contact why did you mow my
pumpkins
uh did they mean to
are you gonna find out when you ask him
did you mow over my pumpkins on purpose
or not and now be careful because you
don't want mr cuban link coming out
no but i think you should say why did
you do it and then let them say what if
they don't know what you're talking
about yeah and if you'll know you'll be
able to read that oh so you think that
maybe they did it and they don't even
know dude pumpkins are very visible
that's what you brought you asked did
they do it i'm probably i know i know i
know so what are you you're [ __ ]
telling me i'm i'm i'm just going along
with you you mow my pumpkins i don't
like when my pumpkins are smashed i
don't like smashing pumpkins despite all
my range i'm still just around the cage
yeah dude they'll know what you mean
um
that was cool when you sing it's cool
when i sing too no it's honestly just
cool mostly when i sing no ah and i want
to be honest and i hate saying it flood
of comments
about how good i am since the last two
episodes
are unreal i love you all i appreciate
you all i know you love my singing chris
hates it you know he's wrong like that
you're all great dude you can't do it
like that what does that mean you can't
do i can't do it like this despite all
my range i'm still just
the canes you can't do it like i don't
want to do it like that well whatever
bro
okay
anyway ask him dude confront direct eye
contact why did you mow my pumpkins
they're your neighbor just knock on
their door
no hi why did your mama probably yeah do
it exactly all right cool
why did you mow my disgusting pumpkin
sunny bloomfield new jersey oh [ __ ] in
my home studio nice close to where we're
from yes i'm a musician uh questions got
to do with that what do you guys do when
you get a
writer's block i know you all are both
creative yeah if you got any tips for us
any little things you like to do to keep
it fun
um let me know i'd love to hear back and
uh there are folks in this world that
get it and that don't and i really feel
like you all too get it so appreciate
you keep doing what you're doing i don't
have a sound board so i'm just gonna
play myself out see you later
oh [ __ ] this guy's [ __ ] cool
oh this [ __ ]
took him all afternoon to do you know
what i mean it took him all afternoon to
do that video that was dope neglected
[ __ ] duties that he had as a [ __ ]
you know what i mean friend and parent
or whatever
he was late picking up his wife at the
airport where have you been sorry dude
look what i made yeah
she forgave him for sure yeah she goes
who's that four and they go these guys
and go oh that's really cool
uh i think that writers my advice to
write people who ask about writer's
block is always the same which is that
in my experience of course i get
writer's block and when i do
when i
panic or get mad at myself or try to
like
do some [ __ ] thing to power through
it it actually makes it worse
you gotta [ __ ] cut the cord and let
it go
and then you will circle back
quicker
and quicker to good writing than you
would have if you
either like put pressure on yourself
made yourself do it [ __ ] got mad at
yourself whatever the [ __ ] you just
gotta [ __ ] let it happen it'll pass
quicker if you do that so if you just
relax and succumb to the writer's block
come to the right so come to the right
if you come to the right yeah come down
so all right so then you what you do is
you
re you what if it lasts like a week
it won't got it wow you're so confident
with this [ __ ] dude it won't unless
you're like
then it will last away you know if you
think you're [ __ ] a bad writer
because you why can't i
just like it happens your brain is just
doing a thing that naturally happens
that was crazy when you went oh that was
literally what i was doing when my
friends were
opting to burn themselves alive last
night that was what i was doing for real
i woke up to it and then i felt like i
fell asleep again and then i woke up to
kristen moving her [ __ ] and it hit my
chest and i go oh and i had a [ __ ]
heart and my [ __ ] was pounding for so
long i couldn't get back to sleep and
then i did an hour later and then i woke
up to her about 10 minutes later [ __ ]
looking at instagram didn't get good
sleep all cause of her and my friends
were opting to [ __ ] burn alive in my
head
all good dude i mean that might be more
why you had a bed night sleep than
kristen you know i think though
you know bad dream will [ __ ] up at night
dude a whole day whole next day
i had a dream where i [ __ ] tripped at
a party and i shot a gun and a bullet
hit daddy even though he's at the party
and dad died because i shot him and i
was like just ruin the entire [ __ ]
next two days senator
can we please get back to what
the issue here healthcare um yeah anyway
uh
let it [ __ ] pass
it will it's my advice let it pass just
let it wash over you how about that okay
yeah right yeah okay
hi guys
a huge fan
i'm a true baby for life um
but i'm gonna say that this podcast
actually might be my new favorite
my question today
is
how would you react to my situation
um check this out i have a stepmom that
has stressed me out for 20 years i have
completely bit my tongue and not brought
up any kind of issue with her for the
sake of everyone around me my sister my
dad
um and it's just
eating away at me um she's just very
passive aggressive it's not even that
crazy i just find her very stressful to
be around and as soon as i had my son
um who's calvin's age and i'm pregnant
with my second right now
i just found it even harder to deal with
yeah um sure
i kind of blew up on her a little bit
for the first time ever
a couple weeks ago
and i'm just deciding now
i think it's time to cut ties
with her stepmother obviously but that
means possibly losing my relationship
with my dad
and i've also
um experienced some guilt from my sister
because it's going to make her life
harder um
wow i think i know what the right call
is and i think i know what you guys will
say but i need your advice to help pump
me up
um
when i'm having moments of weakness with
this decision because i've never put my
foot down or or
established any boundaries
i'm also eight months pregnant and
you're in the right mindset to be doing
this
so
if you have any personal experience that
you can give me for reference or
any other advice that would be great
thanks bye
what a cutie so i think right now do
whatever you want because you're eight
months pregnant just [ __ ] like don't
don't like you can even block a [ __ ]
number if you want or even your dad's
too it's like your right mind's trying
to do what you got to do and don't worry
about explaining it to anybody i think
ultimately a lot in the long run because
if you do want to keep a relationship
with your dad i would say maybe you you
want to just let her know
look if we're going to stay in touch if
we're going to have a relationship
i need it to be like this and this is
what i need from you and this is what i
need you to stop doing and then if she
can't do that
then you walk away and cut the cord
knowing you actually did try to actually
just cut the cord without giving them
the opportunity to meet the criteria
that you have
you it's not that that's a bad idea it's
something that's morally wrong i think
you might end up living with some kind
of regret if you give this woman the
chance to actually
uh
be the kind of person that you want her
to be in your life at least
uh then i think that going forward even
if she can't do it you will feel better
about yourself and your own life
okay so i did the joke where uh
her face opened up and another face came
out right and was a demon and had a big
tongue and goes oh you know yeah and i
missed what is her stepmom doing
she's just passive aggressive and like
making her
we shouldn't get that specific but yeah
she's clearly
being pretty [ __ ] terrible yeah okay
um
button pushing i think is the vibe i got
dude such a [ __ ] [ __ ] up like you
don't choose your family you know like
you gotta [ __ ] be i mean you can i
guess when you get to certain you can
choose to not be around them but like
it's so [ __ ] annoying because like
this doesn't just affect her and her
stepmom this also this will affect her
dad this will affect her sister yes
suspect everyone so you have to kind of
tread lightly even though i what i think
is
you look you blew up it was eight months
you're eight months pregnant you blew up
that's understandable right because your
hormones are going crazy you've got
you're you're you're two people right
now not feel bad about that yeah so
don't feel bad about it i think that the
number one thing is
don't feel bad about how you're feeling
and don't feel guilty about anything
you're a good person
obviously you can tell that just by this
and like
just
just
give yourself permission to not feel a
certain way about how you're feeling
right exactly like you feel the way you
feel and that's fine
i think that's the number one thing and
number two you just got to be direct and
be like look
you know you're being passive aggressive
or whatever the [ __ ] you want to say
it's it's too much and it's it's it's
affecting me
and maybe it's something we can both
talk through i mean dude we have
instances in our lives where we deal
with passive aggressive people all the
time and like
and uh and it's hard and it sucks and
you know
i
i guess i don't know if you do figure it
out let me know too because i need to
know i i think something you said is
important though like don't
put uh any kind of like
edge or judgment or glean on the way
she's making you feel she's making you
feel that way don't be like ah i hate
that she's making me mad i hate that i'm
getting upset at this that's just a
compounding of the problem like she's
doing it that's the end of it you have
your brain she has hers they react in a
certain way and there's nothing anybody
can [ __ ] do about it it's about how
to move on from that whether that's with
her in your life or not
be aware of compounding the problem the
problem already exists don't add any
more to it it's already there for you
uh but yeah don't [ __ ] feel bad about
anything if you end up having to cut out
of your life [ __ ] her it's her fault
yeah cutter chord like you're going to
cut that umbilical chord oh baby when it
comes out but i'm just saying like
there's gonna be two chords at the same
time being symbolic like i'm cutting
this chord and also in my mind i'm
cutting the chord for the stepmom in
fact say it when the doctors cut the
yeah do you know what this means like
this with your
you know what you know what that is too
symbolic of to the doctor yeah the
doctor said okay stay still please no
because what happened is my
my stepmom is really annoying and she's
passive-aggressive so when when we're
cutting this chord i'm imagining that
it's the chord in the mind in my mind
for the stepmom
uh because she's very passionate i don't
want
it's actually like this
[Laughter]
snip
ma'am leave please all right
what's the baby's name
hi guys i am from norway and i work as a
production dancer and the word lets me
travel all over the world and i have to
speak english a lot
but i've not resided in one place for
long enough to pick up either a british
accent or uh
i was gonna make that joke so i've just
kept my norwegian one yeah i have a
broad vocabulary and i don't have a hard
time making myself understood in most
situations so
it works fine my problem is whenever i
do a contract in a country that speaks
english as their first language
and this is solemnly countries that has
english as their first language i get
hassle a lot for my accent and it
includes comments about how i pronounce
different words or my tone and the way i
speak
or what is most common is i get asked
probably four or five times a day
where are you from oh you have an accent
and this includes like grocery store
where i buy food and she would ask do
you want to pay cash or card and i would
say card please and she would say oh you
have an accident where are you from
usually i will politely
tell them that i'm from norway and
most of the times they would have no
idea where norway is what norway is
and i don't see it as my job to educate
them and explain geography
and i find it a waste of my time because
it's happening so many times a day that
i would love if you could help me find a
concise response which i can reply and
kind of
shut down the conversation or is this a
perfect time for a spin move or
should i sit down and learn an accent
and which one dude thank you life i was
in i was in thank you for your uh
submission my
i was in uh high school and remember uh
dojun oh yeah
he oh yeah
he was what was he
he was uh korean he's joined the army
remember he was korean south korean army
yeah oh my god to fight against kim
jong-un
really yeah jesus christ i mean him
up at his doorstep like uh hi uh can i
talk to you you know i mean i always
used to do that i imagine him in the
army you know hey is chris holm um
so uh yeah just like this
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
is kim kim jong
un is he
[Laughter]
and he would say to me
i have been working on my uh
english accent you want to hear and i
would say
sure and then i'll never forget this and
he leaned into my ear really close and
he said
he said
let's have lunch
and i'll never forget that dude do that
learn to learn a [ __ ] regular
english accent
or or it's so un it's i feel bad for her
it's really annoying if someone has a
spin move it's great it is a spin move
nor norway
it's a good time for a spin move but
interesting yes i'm interesting outside
because norway
i think you could just also just be like
chicago you know what i mean it's like
never explain honestly you'll get a
laugh and you'll just be able to [ __ ]
probably get out of a lot of the
situations or quicker if you just say
narnia right and then they'll be like
but i and you're already spinning you're
already gone yeah you've already seen um
that's been mentality so uh yeah or uh
just say
yeah i just either do a joke
or just be like to be like i am hello
paper plastic yes i am from i am from
exactly
jacksonville right yeah yeah yeah yeah
let's have lunch atlanta
i am from atlanta let's have lunch
okay
yeah that is so annoying though i'm
sorry about american speaking countries
dude american speaking you know
you know how we do it
hey guys loving the new podcast so
basically my ex-husband and i we're
together for 10 years we've been apart
now for four he's had a girlfriend that
whole time i've had a boyfriend for the
last three i'm actually pregnant do like
any day now so super exciting but we
both moved on and we're good like no
beef at all the issue is his sister is a
real nasty little c word who made it
very clear the entire relationship that
she hated me for no reason and she is
pissed because we never officially
signed divorce papers initially we
weren't sure what we were doing for a
while and then it just wasn't a big deal
to us because we weren't fighting over
anything so paperwork is stargate at
this point but she keeps going out of
her way to harass me through different
social medias she keeps making new
accounts to
just randomly unprovoked message me and
calling me a ton of nasty names and
being awful to me so i keep blocking her
i don't know what to do my ex is so
upset by this like he's the sweetest
person he just keeps telling her to
leave me alone she's almost 40 like i
shouldn't even be a thought in her life
at this point i don't get it so
what do i do
thanks guys
dude people are so weird with that
social media i know people it's like
what did this person do in the 90s
sickness just sat down and was pissed
off yeah dude
just roll letters you know this is so
weird dude it's like a weird like uh
it's like an epidemic it's like a social
contagion or something the way people
know about this [ __ ]
um i i don't even know what you could do
i mean you're doing the right thing
you're just blocking continue like
ignoring don't engage
um i mean her ex should handle it though
yeah but if you were doing this to an ex
of mine i'd be like chris what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you and it would make you
stop
right somehow yeah that doesn't make any
sense but if i'm mentally uh this woman
is disabled
mentally unstable no question that's the
issue
somebody needs to like get her help
unless so weird unless the x's which it
doesn't sound like it the x is telling
her one thing and also doing a different
thing like being like yeah no writer you
know what i mean but they've been cool
the whole time i don't yeah yeah
well she's maybe it was tumultuous at
some point but it never was she says
there should be some sort of like uh
what do they call it uh when you when
you call um
the the authorities on somebody you
to to check on them
and and and they take them
to a mental place what do they call it
it's like they you're 86 in someone or
something yeah not 86
50 150. uh
that
there should be that kind of a thing
with social media
like
like you get to call somebody and then
they get locked out of their all of
their accounts right yeah and they got
to go to like or some [ __ ] i don't know
yeah or like they get visited
like this is real life mental health but
this is real life like people think
social media is just social media yeah
but it's real life dude this [ __ ]
woman is causing actual mental harm and
stress to people i've been on the other
industry like that before not that
specifically
yeah yeah but it's like it's awful dude
it is yeah it's really really it
actually doesn't bother me but it's
bothered people around me
so so so much and i've seen the pain it
causes people it's really dark [ __ ] yeah
i mean that woman needs
extreme help yeah it's me uh it's not
you but it is youtube but that's what i
was thinking about um i'm telling you
woman needs help but it's also she's
pregnant dude
that's crazy like she's about to pop a
baby out nothing's wrong with this
woman she's scary she's scared of me i'm
scared i'm scared i'm upset man i'm
scared i think that honestly it's the
guy you got to have a clear conversation
i know the guy's upset your ex but you
got to have a clear conversation with
him and be like yo you gotta talk to you
gotta we something has to be done i'm
eight months pregnant whatever the [ __ ]
it is like this woman is stressing me
out i can't be a new mom and be dealing
with blocking these [ __ ] finsta
accounts yeah you know please
please help if you haven't had that
conversation have that conversation yes
exactly and then uh also
uh congratulations on your baby
yeah i'll be in dallas uh i'll be in
wichita i'll be in atlanta and i'll be
in washington dc uh and savannah georgia
go hit up chris leah.com for tickets and
uh we got a bunch of new merch that just
came out and we're working on lifeline
merch we got that coming out so coming
soon uh if you got a question for us
click the link in the description below
or go to watchlifeline.com
uh pretty soon i got something special
for you guys too uh coming up i think
you're gonna like it's this
and uh
do you remember pearl jam do you have a
project yeah you don't though in the
middle of when you were [ __ ] singing
uh yeah
don't call me daughter dude that is un
if i saw that that would be so
no brave [ __ ] up for me
you know what i would do if you were
doing that and i was really worried
about it we were gonna play and i'd do
it with you i would start singing with
you and i would be like sorry that's
just what we do right we're doing it as
a sovereign foreign fun thing yeah like
a bad 80s movie oh yeah so anyway right
right
thanks man appreciate that then we'd
walk off the plane and and the music
would play over the track and don't call
me a daughter in slow motion
yeah
anyway
[Music]
hello
[Music]